want to make common cause with other
parties don't you and groupings to try
to get this stopped what I'm usually
going to follow well I was yesterday
just down in swanage anti-fracking camp
there they protesting there occupying
the land so that the Planning Commission
can't go ahead we're supporting groups
we're very pleased that labour and lib
dems seem to be shifting their position
to where we've been for quite a while we
want to make common cause we want to
have a cross-party reinforced to hold up
fracking in this we're gonna make no
progress on meeting our climate change
targets we're going to liberate
ourselves from climate change the way to
do it is not to dig up more forcible
right but I mean just on the process you
seem to be talking about a twin track
approach then parliamentary approach a
legal approach well maybe a triple track
of protein and direct action well we've
never been afraid you know Caroline
Lucas was arrested anti-fracking protest
we are seeing a very interesting revolt
I think from grassroots local people
will I was with in swanage yesterday
local residents who don't want it
happening on their doorstep they don't
want to happening there cited scientific
interest on the purbeck coast and we're
very happy to support their campaigns
and to work with them and I think we're
seeing a sea change I think people are
getting active around this issue people
are realizing the implications more and
more and of course there's a
parliamentary political route to take as
well you know one of the things about
the Green Party's we do do social
movements as well as the heart and the
legal issue as well I mean you're going
to take that all the way up at the
Supreme Court will certainly be
supporting the legal challenges that
have been going forward absolutely yeah
now tell me about this common cause
we're hearing a lot about it when it
comes to brexit and you know join this
up for me I noticed you and the SMP
applied camry issued a statement didn't
you join the conservative party
conference about trying to hold the
Conservatives to account is this the way
you see yourself going forward you
mentioned there the Labour Party coming
around to your point of view on fracking
there's so many other areas where there
seem to be natural cross over there is
natural crossover we fought the last
general election on sending a clear
message to Westminster we got our
best-ever general election result and I
think that's worked well we're seeing a
lot of the parties now coming around to
our positions there are still huge
differences between us and labor but
where there is common ground we want to
work with people and we also
particularly want to work around the
issue of electoral reform what we saw in
the referendum was a clear cry from many
parts of the country that people felt
they weren't having control then
out getting control over fracking isn't
the government still going in over their
heads over local people but I think the
key to unlocking control is to give
people a say in general elections and to
change the voting system where we can
agree on that will work with him down I
mean just on a statement though it was
only plied the nationalist and the SNP
you joined forces with you keep
mentioning labor and the lib dems why
haven't they signed up which I mean this
was off the back of what Caroline had
done previously with Nicola and Leanne
so it was a natural progression I think
we were really disappointed and this is
a difference with with labour was after
amber Rudd speech we saw a graphic come
out from the Labour Party criticizing
conservatives for not cutting migration
and there are real mixed messages coming
out of the Labour Party we want them
obviously to shift to a much more pro
migrant position and we'll keep
hammering that message away so I think
there are clear differences we want
labor to to work with us where there's
common ground and the lib dems to
absolutely so what's your sense of where
this should go with brexit how it is now
shaped we know the view of Theresa May
brexit means brexit there'll be no
running commentary so presumably the
negotiations take place and then we the
people the parliamentarians are told at
some point this is the deal we've got
you'd obviously like to shape that deal
how we would like to shave that deal but
clearly exactly what you've said we are
very concerned about this is the deal
that we've negotiated you have to take
it I mean this is not what we were
promised during the referendum we were
promised that we would have a chance to
take back control we'd have a greater
say if we voted leave well we're not
getting that on the terms of breaks it
and that we want to campaign very very
hard to stay in the single market we
want freedom of movement we're
absolutely unequivocal about that we
want a parliamentary vote and we'd like
to also see the country have a greater
say free consultation or even through a
general election I mean these are
seismic changes that will affect
generations to come surely it's
important to go to the people and ask
them what they think about the terms or
what about